welcome everybody it's been a very long
night it is the first day
after the 2020 presidential senate and
house election and unfortunately
we really don't have that many results
yet
at least not enough to say who will be
the president of the united states for
the next four years and it's really
difficult to do these shows because
things
move so quickly and then nothing happens
for hours and things move quickly and
because it takes us about 90 minutes to
produce the show
i try in the interests of getting you
all
the most updated and accurate
information on which we can then
go to the next day um it becomes tough
to know exactly when to do the show but
at a certain point
we have to do it and we're doing it
right now so i will give you the
information that is accurate as of
this moment some of this may have
changed and if so at our next
opportunity to be together we will
discuss it
there is not yet a winner in the 2020
presidential election
i will look at specific numbers with you
in a little bit
but as of this morning the associated
press had it 238 electoral votes for
joseph r biden jr
the democratic candidate and 213
electoral votes for donald trump
and yet donald trump declared victory
late last night early this morning i
will have clips of that for you that is
exactly as i predicted but the most
important reminder i have
and this was starting to become an issue
on last night's stream
we anticipated this scenario we had
um over one and a half million different
people
including nearly a hundred thousand at a
time watched the live stream of the
results last night
and panic was rapidly rising i had
people in europe calling it was
four five in the morning there they were
up all night watching the numbers
we have to remember the red mirage
scenario now
trump may win biden may win this was an
election
because we knew that there were going to
be
postal delays partially caused by the
president's postmaster general there are
now 300 000 potentially missing ballots
which i will tell you about
i will tell you all of what is going on
some states
which count in person and report
in-person ballots first
and then start counting the mail-in
ballots we knew of a potential red
mirage scenario where states would
look like they were going trump and as
the ballots are counted
they start looking towards biden we
already have two examples of this
wisconsin and michigan they are not
final numbers yet but wisconsin and
michigan
all night yesterday even until midnight
and later
were looking like wow trump's crushing
michigan
and slowly but surely the numbers have
shifted and are now
leaning in favor of joseph r biden jr so
panic does not serve us well in these
situations
we don't think clearly when we're
panicking and importantly
we're panicking over things we can't
control
if we learn about ballots being thrown
out then yes we activate
and we start calling the people who need
to be called
and complaining and making a lot of
noise but merely waiting for ballots to
be counted when we anticipated a red
mirage scenario doesn't serve us well
and in fact as i tweeted last night
around 12 30 in the morning
remember how we were warned about a red
mirage
and not to panic at midnight on tuesday
i'm going to bed many vote counts don't
even resume
until the morning and indeed that's what
i did
and indeed as the vote counts have
resumed the numbers have started to
shift in joe biden's favor in a number
of states
i'm speaking generally now i will get to
specifics in the next segment now as a
quick reminder in the midst of all of
this
remember we still have a pandemic we had
another
nearly hundred thousand cases yesterday
and on top of all of the normal delays
that can sometimes happen
on top of the delays that we're aware of
in the mail on top of all of these other
things
most states are also being relatively
safe when it comes to the pandemic in
terms of election staff
and counting and all of these things so
let's not forget about that reality
as we discuss the election results so
momentarily we're going to do a deep
dive into the presidential map
in terms of the senate we still don't
know who will control the senate right
now democrats have flipped
two seats john hickenlooper won in
colorado
and mark kelly defeating the incumbent
republican vile
republican martha mcsally in arizona
republicans have also flipped one seat
we expected that democratic senator doug
jones would lose in alabama and he did
so that's
democrats plus two republicans plus one
that is one seat in the direction of
democrats so far
otherwise counting continues in the
house of representatives votes
still being counted as of one moment
earlier today
democrats securing 190 seats flipping
two from republicans republicans
securing 181
flipping six meaning a net gain of
four for republicans with 64 seats
remaining to count i'm going to take
some time
to go through the presidential numbers
in a moment
this is going to take some time as long
as we're confident
in the votes being counted it doesn't
bother me although i understand
it is stressful and anxiety producing
the problem we're up against is donald
trump is trying to end the election now
donald trump has declared victory donald
trump declared that he won
states which it's not actually clear
that he won
and we know of hundreds of thousands of
votes that are potentially missing and
we're going to cover
all of it for you today if you've been
watching the show you've probably heard
me talk about how much i love my helix
mattress well i was really excited to
hear that helix has launched
a new company called all form which
makes premium customizable
sofas and chairs with the same level of
quality
and comfort that i expect from these
guys and all form is one of our sponsors
today
they're giving you twenty percent off at
allforum.com pacman
they actually sent me a couch which i
put in my living room
at home it's now my favorite piece of
furniture
in the house it took me just minutes to
set it up
it's solidly built it's huge it's roomy
it has a modern minimalist design which
i love but it's also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality it has become the
focal point of my living room
their prices are very reasonable and
when you get a new sofa or chair
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it and the best part is
everything comes with a lifetime
warranty
stop buying poorly made furniture go to
customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now and get
twenty percent off your entire order
when you get there
by going to all form dot com slash
pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video